This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the signs of mental toughness,
这是一个iHeart播客。真人保证。2%。这就是在有自动扶梯可用时，依然选择走楼梯的人数比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。欢迎收听我的播客《2%》。我将在节目中剖析在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中，
fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
精神坚韧、保持体能以及培养韧性的秘诀。经历一些磨难，你会破茧成蝶，成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的自己。在iHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方，搜索并收听《2%》。即数字“TWO”加“percent”。
On The Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s.
欢迎收听《回首当年》播客。从1979年开始，那对我和我来说是个重要的时刻。对我也意义重大。我是山姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利什。每集节目中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。我们的嘉宾包括朋友、同行喜剧演员以及我们最喜爱的作家。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈论80年代。
84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host, Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor.
84年是个疯狂的年份。确实是个疯狂的年份。我认为对黑人群体而言，没有比这更重要的年份了。在iHeartRadio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《回首当年》。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？你们正在收听由你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主播科尔·盖恩斯主持的《知难而进》。这个空间专注于黑人男性的经历，进行那些在其他地方绝对不安全的坦诚对话，但在这里，你是在和一位懂行的持证专业人士交流。有多少男人背负着一副盔甲。
It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you've done. need to. Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins, but the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice in so much. I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian. Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped.
它向世界发出信号，表明你是不容好惹的。但这并不意味着仅仅因为你有这种能力，你就。必须这么做。在iHeartRadio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《知难而进》。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的生父，但这段怀孕经历似乎是一场骗局。你伪造了这份特定的检测报告两次，不仅如此。我伪造了一次检测。这需要一大批互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格，一名女同性恋者。迈克尔·曼奇尼。我的天哪。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《情网难逃》。
Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody, welcome back to this show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. It is so great to have you here back for another episode, perhaps the most quintessential 20-something episode we have done in a while. Today, we're going to talk about the sensation of feeling lost after university and struggling to figure out kind of what we're doing
劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于要承担后果了。在iHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《情网难逃》播客。大家好，欢迎回到《你二十多岁的心理学》，在这个播客中，我们探讨二十多岁时的一些重大生活变化和转型，以及它们对我们心理意味着什么。大家好，欢迎回到本节目。欢迎回到本播客。新听友，老听友，无论你身处世界的哪个角落。非常高兴你能回来收听另一期节目，这或许是我们这段时间以来最具二十岁代表性的一期节目。今天，我们要聊聊大学毕业后那种感到迷茫的感觉，以及在弄清楚我们究竟在做什么时的挣扎。
with our lives, a lot of that career confusion. College, university, for those of us who have the opportunity to go, feels like a bit of a really safe bubble, a bit of a magical whirlwind. Like, we're getting a bit of a teaser for adulthood, and it's exciting and we have so much freedom. And there's this very singular goal that we're working towards, but working towards graduation. And whatever comes after that kind of feels like a really, really, you're really, big ominous cloud, something that we can both ignore, but are also very increasingly aware of. That weighs, that decision paralysis, that sense of what is going to come next, weighs really heavily on our mind, I think, the closer that it gets. If you are experiencing some of that
伴随而来的很多职业困惑。对于我们这些有机会上大学的人来说，大学就像是一个真正安全的泡沫，一场神奇的旋风。感觉就像是我们提前体验了一下成年生活，这令人兴奋，而且我们拥有如此多的自由。我们朝着一个非常单一的目标努力，那就是为了毕业而奋斗。在那之后发生的一切，感觉就像是一片非常非常、巨大而阴森的云，是我们既可以忽视，但又越来越能意识到的东西。那种负担，那种决策麻木感，那种对接下来会发生什么的感觉，随着时间的临近，我认为它沉重地压在我们的心头。如果你正在经历一些
anticipatory anxiety around where do I go to next, or perhaps you're in that period right now, facing the post-graduation blues, I really empathize with you. I think it's not an easy transition, but it's also not one that we speak about enough. I think we expect people to leave university, leave college, and have some grand idea or some path forward. And very rarely, I think, does that happen? Very rarely, do we have the answers to all of those questions that we are going to face post-graduation? Like, what do I actually? want to do with my life? What is going to make me feel fulfilled? What are my goals? What is my vision? Am I happy right now? What am I going to do when I start losing my friends? So many things that
对下一步何去何从的预期焦虑，或者你现在正处于那个阶段，面临着毕业后的失落感，我真的非常感同身受。我认为这不是一次轻松的转变，但这也是一个我们谈论得不够的话题。我认为我们期望人们离开大学后，能有个宏伟的想法或某种前进的道路。但我认为这种情况极少发生。我们极少能拥有所有那些在毕业后将面临的问题的答案？比如，我到底？想在生活中做些什么？什么能让我感到充实？我的目标是什么？我的愿景是什么？我现在快乐吗？当我开始失去朋友时，我要怎么办？有太多的事情
kind of pile up. And I think that that's something that we really need to talk about. That experience is one that we haven't spoken about on the show despite it being really important. The one thing that our 20s promise us, and I say this all the time, is choice and change. No matter where you are in the world, who you are, the plans you might envision, this decade is going to throw you a lot of curve balls, some of which we can predict and some that we can't. I think that's all part of the game, part of the fun of being in this transitional period of life. But it's also why we kind of colloquially hear about our 20s being called the panic years, the panic of having to find yourself amongst discovering the things that society expects from you, such as our career, the types of
堆积在一起。我认为这是我们真正需要谈论的事情。尽管这种经历非常重要，但我们却在节目中很少谈论它。我们的二十多岁向我们承诺的一件事，我一直这么说，那就是选择和改变。无论你身处世界的哪个角落，无论你是谁，无论你可能设想过什么计划，这个十年都会给你抛出许多意料之外的曲线球，其中一些我们可以预测，而另一些则不能。我认为这正是整场游戏的一部分，也是处于人生这个转型期的乐趣所在。但这也就是为什么我们在口头上经常听到我们的二十多岁被称为“恐慌岁月”，那种在发现社会对你的期望（比如我们的职业、我们想要的
relationships we want, the type of person that we want to be. Graduating university and having to discover who you are beyond the structure of schooling is one of those curveballs, even if we anticipate it because what it does is it presents accumulation, of a lot of life stresses and changes that naturally leave us feeling very overwhelmed, perhaps even a little bit aimless. It kind of feels like the first chapter of adulthood is actually beginning, whilst that former chapter is closing, one that we are probably very nostalgic for, one that we possibly really enjoyed.
人际关系、我们想要成为什么样的人）的同时，又不得不去寻找自我的恐慌。大学毕业后，不得不去发现在学校体制之外的你是谁，就是那些曲线球之一，即使我们对此有所预期，因为这实际上是许多生活压力和变化的积累，它们自然而然地让我们感到非常不知所措，甚至可能有点漫无目的。这种感觉就像成年生活的第一章节才刚刚开始，与此同时，前一个章节正在落下帷幕，那是一个我们可能非常怀念、可能真的很喜欢的章节。
So it's actually coined its very own phrase known as post-graduation blues or depression, and it's not a clinical term, I will state that, as of yet, at least. But the fact that we have a term for an experience a lot of us go through kind of goes to show how universal it is to feel anxious, to feel uncomfortable, to feel stuck, even depressed or lost after university. And perhaps you needed that reminder that you are not the only one. And it's a combination, in my opinion, of four factors in particular that leave us in this emotional, kind of a mental state of stagnation.
所以它实际上催生了自己的专属短语，被称为“毕业后失落症”或“抑郁症”，我得说明一下，至少目前它还不是一个临床术语。但我们为许多人经历的这种感受创造了一个术语，这恰恰说明了大学毕业后感到焦虑、感到不舒服、感到困惑，甚至抑郁或迷茫是多么的普遍。也许你需要这样一个提醒：你不是唯一一个有这种感受的人。在我看来，这尤其是四个因素共同作用的结果，它们让我们陷入了这种情感和精神上的停滞状态。
Oftentimes, we just think about the confusion associated with needing to fully act as an adult and make choices when it comes to finding a job. But it's also, firstly, losing friends post-graduation and no longer having that natural, convenient friend group formed around you based on the fact that you are all at a similar stage in life and in the same place. You really do begin to notice some of those friendships of convenience. It's something we're all going to experience the scattering of friends across the country, even across the globe. And so it feels like suddenly, out of the blue, you're quite isolated after years of having your friends live just around the corner or down the
通常，我们只想到需要完全表现得像个成年人并在找工作时做出选择所带来的困惑。但首先，它也是毕业后失去朋友，身边不再有基于“大家处于人生相似阶段且身处同一地点”而自然、便捷形成的死党圈子。你确实开始注意到其中一些只是权宜之交的友谊。这是我们所有人都会经历的事情——朋友散落全国各地，甚至是全球各地。所以感觉就像是突然之间，在经历了多年朋友就住在转角或街区那头的生活之后，毕业后你变得相当孤立，没有了那种支持系统，会感觉非常孤独。我向你保证，这完全是正常的。我毕业后对此感触极深。作为那些（你知道的）搬离了大学所在地的人之一，我确实失去了朋友，我不觉得说出这一点有什么不自在。但我注意到的是，你不会失去那些你真正想要维系的人，那些与你有着极深联系的人。如果有的话，我认为这是一个重要的过渡时刻，因为你摆脱了一些可能并不像你想象中那么有意义的关系。而大学毕业，正是你获得这种视角的时候。
block, it feels really lonely to not have that support system. I promise that that is completely normal. I felt it immensely after I graduated. As one of the people who, you know, did move away from where I went to university, I did lose friends and that's something that I don't feel uncomfortable saying. But the thing that I've noticed is that you're not going to lose the people you truly want to hang on to, the ones that you have a very deep connection with. If anything, I think it's an important transitional moment because you shed some of those relationships that perhaps were not as meaningful as you imagined. And post-graduation, graduating university, is when you gain that perspective.
我真的很喜欢用一种方式来和朋友保持联系。就是通过一个叫Agape的应用程序。好吧，这不是赞助。我只是他们作品的超级粉丝。所以这基本上就是：你每天或在你喜欢的任何时候发送一个问题，来引发关于你日常生活中的事情的对话。故事、有趣时刻、更深层的话题，你和你的朋友甚至伴侣全天都可以各自回答，并看到对方的反应。
There is like one way that I really like to stay in touch with my friends. And it's through this app called Agape. Okay, this is not sponsored. I'm just a really huge fan of their work. So it's essentially where you send a question once a day or whenever you would like that spur conversation about what's going on in your daily life. Stories, funny moments, deeper topics, and you and your friend or even your partner each get to answer throughout the day and see the other person's response.
老实说，当我发现这个应用时，它简直太颠覆游戏规则了。但除此之外，像安排FaceToTime通话和见面旅行、把这变成一件有仪式感的事，在毕业后的这段时期里也意义重大。你也会为这个新篇章结新朋友。我向你保证，职场朋友、旅行朋友，以及那种你某天偶遇，突然觉得仿佛认识了一辈子的那种人。这些人正走进你的生活。他们在路上了。他们已经在那里了。只是你还没遇到他们。所以我想说，我知道看到你的朋友圈有些四分五裂，真的压力很大，
Honestly, when I discovered this app, it was such a game changer. But also things like planning FaceTime. and trips to see each other making an event out of it is so meaningful in that post-graduation period. You'll also make new friends for this new chapter. I really do guarantee it, work friends and travel friends and those kind of people that you just meet one day and suddenly, it feels like you've known them forever. Those people are coming into your life. They are on their way. They are already out there. You just haven't met them yet. So I would say, say I understand that it's really stressful seeing perhaps your friend group kind of splinter,
但它最终会回到你身边。你总会找到度过难关的方法。导致这种压力的第二个因素是财务焦虑。我们中的很多人，包括我自己，大学毕业时都背负着某种债务或面临财务不稳定，这让我们真正感到了要立即开始赚钱来偿还贷款、支付账单、仅仅为了维持成年人生活方式的压力。事实上，这真的很有趣，因为与大量学生贷款债务相关的、即将到来的财务厄运感，确实对我们的心理健康和应对能力产生了负面影响。曾有一项研究表明，大约62%的美国人（这项研究是在美国进行的）表示，他们经历过某种程度的压力、焦虑、压力
but it does find its way back to you. You do find a way through it. The second factor, contributing to this stress, is financial anxiety. A lot of us, myself included Finnish College University, with some kind of debt or financial insecurity whereby we really feel the pressure to start earning money immediately, to pay off our loans, to pay our bills, to just pay for an adult lifestyle. In fact, it's really interesting because that sense of impending financial doom associated with a lot of student loan debt really does negatively impact our mental health and our sense of coping. There was a study done that around 62% of Americans, it was conducted in the US, they reported that they experienced some sense of stress, anxiety, pressure
这与一毕业就必须赚钱来还清债务有关。我认为，没有找到全职工作所带来的压力，也同样令人难以置信地感到焦虑。说实话，我记得从亲身经历来看，我毕业后的第二天就在查自己背了多少债务，字面意思就是毕业后的第二天，当时整个人都说不出话来。而且我要完全老实说。四年后的今天，我依然没有把那些债务全还清。财务焦虑和这种我们正在经历的巨大的生活压力源，
associated with needing to make money straight out of university to pay back their debt. I think the stress of also maybe not having a full-time job lined up is also incredibly just anxiety-inducing. I remember speaking from experience, checking how much debt I was in the day after I graduated, literally the day after I graduated and being speechless. And I'm going to be completely honest. I still have not paid all of that off some four years later. Financial anxiety and this sort of massive life stressor that we're experiencing
我们总是担心钱，总是担心我们作为成年人该如何自立。这让我们觉得我们需要非常快地做出决定。我们需要一开局就找到一份真正的成年人的工作，一份高薪的成年人工作。哪怕你足够幸运，毕业时没有负债，但我认为，作为一个大学生与作为一个毕业生相比，面临着不同水平的开支，同时也伴随着一种不同的期望，即你应该已经在建立某种职业生涯、为买房存钱或制定某种长期财务计划的路上了。而这种财务焦虑会导致
where we're always worrying about money and we're always worried about how we're going to kind of get on our feet as adults. It makes us feel like we need to make decisions really quickly. We need to get a real adult job, a high-paying adult job. right out of the gate. And even if you are lucky enough to graduate with no debt, I think being a college student versus being a graduate comes with a different level of expenses, but also a different expectation that you should kind of be on your way to building some sort of career or saving for a home or some kind of long-term financial plan. And that financial anxiety causes
大量的压力。对我们许多人来说，它会导致许多不眠之夜。它还会让我们觉得，我们真的需要在此时此刻、立刻马上开始完成我们想要的所有事情。就像我们必须一次性做出所有的举动一样。但说实话，美好的事物需要时间，需要勤奋，需要坚持，有时还需要一点点运气。如果现在事情进展不顺利，如果你没有在做你的梦想工作，或者没有在你希望做的事情上取得成功。如果你现在没有处于你想要的位置，只要记住，几年之内很多事情都会改变，
a lot of stress. For many of us, it can lead to a lot of sleepless nights. It can also make us feel like we really need to start accomplishing all the things we want right now at once in this moment. Like we kind of have to make all of our moves at once. But honestly, good things take time and they take diligence and they take consistency and sometimes just a little bit of luck. If it's not working out right now, if you are not working your dream job, or succeeding in everything that you wish you were doing. If you're not where you want to be at the moment, just remember a lot can change in a few years,
以我过来人的经验来说，最好的道路、最好的旅程往往不是一帆风顺的、不是轻而易举的。我也认为在这个过渡时期，存在一种内在的竞争感和比较心，尤其是在大学毕业后的求职季。我记得我快要离开大学时申请毕业后的工作，结果A，被其中许多工作拒绝了，B，仅仅是
speaking from experience, and kind of the best paths, the best journeys are ones that are not seamless, that they're not easy. I also think there's a really inherent sense of competition and comparison during this transitional period, especially around the post-college job hunt. I remember applying for graduate jobs when I was about to leave university, and A, getting rejected from a lot of them, and B, just
意识到外面有很多有能力的人，我们到底要怎么才能找到工作呢？我真的能在一个让我满意的地方工作或做点什么吗？这与朝九晚五工作的绝对恐惧结合在一起，鉴于我以前在学习期间以及做临时或季节性工作时所拥有的自由，这种工作对我来说显得太不自然了。每周五天、每天八小时的工作制是一个巨大的调整。这种生活方式的改变让人感觉你的生活现在必须围绕着工作来安排。
realizing that there are a lot of competent people out there, how in the world are we all going to find jobs? Will I actually be able to work somewhere or do something where I'm satisfied? And that was also combined with the absolute terror of working a 9 to 5, which just felt so unnatural to me given the previous freedom I had when I was studying. and working casual or seasonal jobs. It's a huge adjustment to enter into an eight-hour work week five days a week. There's this kind of lifestyle change where it feels like your life now needs to fit in around your job.
这真的让人筋疲力尽。我总是对那些为此苦苦挣扎的人说，给它六个月的时间，给你的身体和心灵六个月的时间去适应并找到自己的节奏，因为最初的一小段时间将会是一场挣扎，
And it's really exhausting. I always say to people who are struggling with that to just give it six months, give your body and your mind six months to adapt and find its rhythm because that first little period is going to be a struggle. and you may even question whether this is really the life for you, which I think is an important question to ask, to not be afraid of. And I think it's one that more and more of us are questioning each year. Is the nine to five really the optimal way of living and working? Because it doesn't feel inherently fulfilling. And it can feel really, really terrifying. And that really brings me to my next
你甚至可能会质疑这是否真的是你想要的生活，我认为这是一个重要的问题，不要害怕去问。而且我认为这是我们每年有越来越多的人在质疑的问题。朝九晚五真的是生活和工作的最佳方式吗？因为它感觉不到本质上的充实。而且它可能会让人感到非常非常可怕。这真的把引出了我的下一个
point, which has to do with choice overload. We talk about this concept a lot on the podcast because I think it's one of the defining theories of our 20s, but for a refresh, in psychology, choice overload refers to having too many choices or options such that it actually causes decision or analysis paralysis. It actually makes us, it makes it harder for us to pick between them, which is counterintuitive, but they've done studies on this with actual postgraduate students whereby the more options they perceived having available to them, the more likely they were to struggle with feeling satisfied choosing just one, because they were a lot more fearful of the what if. What if I make the wrong choice and regret it? That can make us feel very lost,
观点，这与选择过载有关。我们在播客中经常讨论这个概念，因为我认为这是我们二十多岁时的决定性理论之一，但为了复习一下，在心理学中，选择过载是指有太多的选择或选项，以至于它实际上导致了决策或分析麻痹。它实际上让我们、让我们更难在它们之间做出选择，这与直觉相反，但他们对实际的应届毕业生做过这方面的研究，结果表明，他们觉得可供选择的选项越多，他们在只选择一个时就越难感到满意，因为他们对“如果……会怎样”更加恐惧。如果我做出错误的选择并为此后悔怎么办？这会让我们感到非常迷失，
having to choose between so many different possible pathways. And humans, we just like to have fewer choices because it means fewer scenarios to weigh up, fewer cost-benefit analysis to conduct. But in our 20s, we are presented with a lot of different forks in the road or the path. Do you start the corporate job? Do you go travelling for a while?
不得不在这么多不同的可能路径之间做出选择。而人类，我们就是喜欢有较少的选择，因为这意味着需要权衡的情景更少，需要进行的成本效益分析更少。但在我们的二十多岁时，我们面前摆着许多不同的岔路口或道路。你是开始一份公司的工作？还是去旅行一段时间？
Do you do some postgraduate education? Or do you keep working your retail or your hospital? job until you find something you love. Do you pursue your big creative dream? Each of these scenarios comes with pros and cons. They have their benefits, but they also have their downsides. And deciding between them can feel like we're kind of closing more doors for ourselves than we're opening. And I think one of the worst realizations or fears we can have is what if we are limiting ourselves too young too soon, it's a fear of missing out, not just on a social scale, but a fear of missing out on life. I honestly think personally this is a massive fallacy. The fallacy that
你是继续读个研究生教育？还是继续做零售或医院的工作，直到你找到真正热爱的事情？你是去追求你伟大的创意梦想吗？这些情景中的每一个都伴随着利与弊。它们有好处，但也有缺点。在它们之间做决定，感觉就像我们在为自己关闭更多的门，而不是打开更多的门。而且我认为最糟糕的认识或恐惧之一就是：如果我们太年轻、太早地限制了自己怎么办？这是一种错失恐惧症，不仅是在社交层面，也是一种对错过人生的恐惧。老实说，我个人认为这是一个巨大的谬论。这个谬论就是
we can't have it all, we can't live all those different lives that we want to live. I think you can't have it all at once at the same time. I spoke about this on our milestone anxiety episode. but I think it still does ring true. I'd like to think of my 20s like a series of chapters or seasons, kind of like your favorite TV show where each season sees the character changing or in some new environment or relationship, having some new experience. Season 1 is 20 to 22. It's kind of our founding years.
我们不能拥有一切，我们不能过上所有我们想要过的不同生活。我认为你不能同时拥有一切。我在关于里程碑焦虑的那期节目中谈到过这一点，但我认为它依然正确。我喜欢把我的二十多岁想象成一系列的章节或季节，有点像你最喜欢的电视剧，每一季中的角色都在改变，或处于某种新环境或新关系中，拥有一些新的体验。第一季是20到22岁。这有点像是我们的奠基岁月。
It's our coming of age season. Season 2, 23 to 24, we're getting on our feet. maybe we have our first job. We've moved to a new city or into a new apartment or a sharehouse. There's new characters. There's new environments. Season 3 is 25 to 26. Season 4, obviously 27 to 28.
这是我们的成长期。第二季，23到24岁，我们开始站稳脚跟。也许我们有了第一份工作。我们搬到了一座新城市，或者搬进了一个新公寓或合租房。有新角色。有新环境。第三季是25到26岁。第四季，显然是27到28岁。
And season 5, the finale, 29 to 30. Your 20s are not just one long chapter, one big chunk of years. You have at least, depending on how you see it, five seasons in this decade, five two-year seasons that you can choose to feel with whatever you envision. You can start jobs and quit jobs. You can fall in love and out of love. Cut your hair, let it grow back again, travel, return home. You can spend a year doing nothing but pursuing some deep, creative passion because you have nine other years during this decade to figure it out. And also it doesn't end there. You know, it's not like your whole.
第五季，大结局，29到30岁。你的二十多岁不只是一长章，也不是几年一大块。在这个十年里，你至少拥有（取决于你怎么看）五个季节，五个你可以选择用你所设想的一切去填满的两年一季。你可以开始工作，也可以辞职。你可以坠入爱河，也可以失恋。剪短头发，让它重新长出来，去旅行，然后回家。你可以花一年的时间什么都不做，只是去追求某个深层的创意激情，因为在这个十年里，你还有另外九年的时间去弄清楚它。而且它并不止于此。你知道的，这并不是说你的整个
30s are a death sentence or the end of the road. I think the biggest myth that we tell ourselves post-graduation is that the most exciting chapter in our lives has come to an end. And I can solidly tell you that that is not the case. Nostalgia will keep you stuck feeling that way. Nostalgia for the uni days, for the good times. But this is really the beginning. I just cannot stress enough. this is the beginning of something amazing and you are going to experience so many surprises that life is going to hand your way that perhaps you right now and your state of post-graduation blues just can't really foresee. And I think that short-sightedness often comes from a place of transitional anxiety. So transitional anxiety is kind of, it's a form of anxiety, obviously,
三十多岁就是死刑宣判或路的尽头。我认为我们在毕业后告诉自己的最大神话是，我们生活中最激动人心的篇章已经结束了。我可以非常坚定地告诉你们，事实并非如此。怀旧会让你陷入这种感觉中无法自拔。对大学时光的怀旧，对美好时光的怀旧。但这其实才刚刚开始。我怎么强调都不为过，这是一场精彩事物的开端，你将体验到生活带给你的无数惊喜，也许你现在处于毕业后失落症状态中的自己还无法真正预见到这一点。我认为这种短视通常源于过渡焦虑。所以过渡焦虑是一种，显然是一种焦虑的形式，
a form of stress and worry that primarily comes from a significant. significant life change. Humans, we are creatures of comfort. We don't like huge events that upend our sense of stability, security or emotional homeostasis, kind of that sense of internal calmness and consistency. Graduating university, although it feels very positive, it is a moment of celebration, it is a massive accomplishment, it is also still a source of stress because we are transitioning from one chapter of our life to the next, one in which we are going to encounter novel and new situations that we haven't necessarily practiced for because we've never been exposed to them, one where we really can't predict what's going to happen next.
一种主要来自重大的压力和担忧。重大的生活变化。人类是舒适的生物。我们不喜欢打乱我们的稳定感、安全感或情绪稳态（即那种内心的平静和一致性）的巨大事件。大学毕业，尽管感觉非常积极，是一个庆祝的时刻，是一个巨大的成就，但它仍然是一个压力的来源，因为我们正在从人生的一个篇章过渡到下一个篇章，在那个篇章中，我们将遇到新颖的、我们没有必然练习过的新情况，因为我们从未接触过它们，在那个篇章中，我们真的无法预测接下来会发生什么。
And if you think about it, graduating, especially from college or university, is really you exiting almost two decades of a very familiar, structured way of living. and operating. For most of us, we go from primary school to high school to college. That is the last 15 years of your life in the schooling system, working, behaving in a very similar way, doing this same kind of task just at a gradually increasing intensity. Kind of all you've ever known since you were a child is this one way of doing things in pursuit of this large goal that seems really far away until you graduate, until it's happening right now. And then it's over. You stop studying for perhaps the first time in your life. And all of your goals that you've had for so long suddenly are
如果你仔细想想，毕业（尤其是大学或学院毕业）真的是你退出了几乎长达二十年的、非常熟悉且结构化的生活和运作方式。对于我们大多数人来说，我们从小学到高中再到大学。那是你在学校体制内的过去15年，以非常相似的方式工作、行为，做着同一种任务，只是强度在逐渐增加。从你还是个孩子起，你所知道的一切就是这种做事方式，为了追求那个在毕业之前、在它真正发生之前看起来还很遥远的宏伟目标。然后它就结束了。你可能一生中第一次停止了学习。你长期以来所有的目标突然都
accomplished and it shifts to something bigger and something intangible. You are no longer working towards that one thing that you have been striving for since you entered the education system. And that can be a catalyst for a lack of purpose. And purpose is, something that we all need. It's a deep psychological need to feel fulfilled and to feel meaningful. I think it also comes with a lot of joy as well and a huge sense of relief. 15 years is a massive marathon of effort and hours and you are probably exhausted by the time you get to the end. But it's also the end to a structure and a daily routine that we're familiar with. In that environment, it's also very easy to define success. You know, there is a correlation between effort and results. You study harder. You get A's. You succeed. You're praised. Post-university adult life does not operate in the same way. So it is confusing to be in this new system where sometimes you aren't rewarded for effort. Sometimes you can work really hard towards your dreams and it's not correlated with success.
实现了，并且转变成了更宏大、更无形的东西。你不再为那个自从你进入教育系统以来一直为之奋斗的目标而努力了。这会成为缺乏目标感的催化剂。而目标感是，我们所有人都需要的东西。这是一种深层的心理需求，需要感到充实和有意义。我认为它也伴随着大量的喜悦以及巨大的解脱感。15年是一场巨大的马拉松，充满了付出和时间，当你走到终点时，你可能已经筋疲力尽了。但这也是对我们所熟悉的结构和日常常规的一种终结。在这种环境中，定义成功也非常容易。你知道的，努力和结果之间存在着相关性。你努力学习。你拿A。你成功了。你受到表扬。大学毕业后的成年生活并不是这样运作的。所以，处在这个有时你的努力得不到回报的新系统中，会让人感到困惑。有时你会为梦想付出很多努力，但这与成功并不相关。
So we have that combined shock to the system where, A, we've never known anything different and we're having to figure that out. And B, we've achieved the thing that we've been working for and towards for decades. So now what? What next? What next? It's a really common conundrum. But here's the secret. No one has a clue. And everyone who looks like they do has just faked it really well until they've figured it out. honestly myself included, I think I'm still faking it most days. And you are highly capable, you are adaptable, you have faced change and challenges before. This is just the next quest, the next opportunity to kind of test your character and grow as millions have done before you and come out the other side. It's also important, especially when it comes to career confusion
所以我们承受着那种复合型的系统冲击，即A，我们从未见过不同的一切，我们必须去弄清楚它；B，我们已经实现了几十年来一直为之努力和奋斗的目标。那么现在呢？接下来呢？接下来呢？这是一个非常普遍的难题。但秘密在于：没有人有一点头绪。而那些看起来胸有成竹的人，只是在找到方法之前伪装得很好罢了。老实说，包括我自己，我想我大多数日子都还在伪装。而你能力极强，你适应力强，你以前也面对过改变和挑战。这只是下一个任务，是考验你的性格并像千百万人之前所做的那样成长并脱颖而出的下一个机会。同样重要的是，特别是当涉及到职业困惑
or not knowing what you actually want to do in your life, to de-center work from your sense of identity. The way you choose to make money is only one facet to who you are. Your career is only one small element of your self-concept. And once we take that off a pedestal, we are able to enjoy life for all of its nuances and small joys, rather than feeling this pressure to be 100% satisfied with our jobs or feel lost when that one component of our life is perhaps not going so well or we're still confused. Think of your life
或者不知道你到底想在生活中做什么时，将工作从你的身份感中剥离出来。你选择赚钱的方式只是你这个人的一小部分。你的职业只是你自我概念中的一小部分。一旦我们把工作从神坛上请下来，我们就能够享受生活的方方面面以及其中的小确幸，而不是感到这种必须对工作100%满意、或者当生活中的那个组件可能不太顺利或我们仍然感到困惑时就会感到迷失的压力。把你的生活
and your identity as a series of buckets that include your relationships, your friends, your family, your partners, your hobbies, the things that make you feel content and excited, what you like doing beyond work, your goals, the broader things in life that you want to work towards, your physical and mental health, your values, how you want to behave, who you want to be, your passions, you know, that's more than hobbies, more than values. What are the things that you can spend hours talking about? You know, what kind of Wikipedia page would you know back to front? What's an issue that you find meaningful?
和你的身份想象成一系列的桶，其中包括你的人际关系、你的朋友、你的家人、你的伴侣、你的爱好、那些让你感到满足和兴奋的事情、你喜欢在工作之外做什么、你的目标、你想要为之奋斗的生活中更广阔的事情、你的身心健康、你的价值观、你想要如何行为、你想成为谁、你的激情所在（你知道的，这不仅仅是爱好，不仅仅是价值观。有哪些事情你可以花几个小时谈论？你知道的，你会把哪种维基百科页面从头到尾背下来？有什么问题是你觉得有意义的）？
You need to fill all of those buckets equally. You need to pour your time and your energy and your effort into all those things to feel fulfilled. And I think I see people get into trouble when they don't diversify who they are. They see themselves as just their careers and they neglect their relationships. They neglect their health. They neglect their passions because we are increasingly living in a world in a society where professional success is a determinant of your self-worth. And yet we did not evolve to be those kinds of creatures.
你需要平等地填满所有这些桶。你需要把你的时间、精力和努力倾注到所有这些事情中，才能感到充实。我认为我看到人们陷入麻烦，是因为他们没有让自己的身份多元化。他们把自己仅仅视为他们的职业，而忽视了自己的人际关系。他们忽视了自己的健康。他们忽视了自己的激情，因为我们越来越生活在一个职业成功是决定你自我价值的标准的社会中。然而，我们进化出来并不是为了成为那种生物。
We evolved to live multi-dimensional lives. And I would say amongst all of those buckets that make up your identity, what you do for work is probably the least important if those other facets of yourself remain full and alive. It's like that thing that people always say, you know, you're never going to wish that you'd spent more time in the office and when things like sickness or when your relationships are falling apart or when there's something happening in your family work always goes on the back burner, right? It's not the most important
我们进化是为了过上多维度的生活。我要说的是，在构成你身份的所有这些桶中，你为了工作所做的事情可能是最不重要的，只要你自我的其他方面保持充实和充满活力。就像人们常说的那样，你知道的，你绝不会希望自己在办公室里呆的时间更多；当疾病降临、当你的关系破裂、或者当你的家庭发生事情时，工作总是会被抛到脑后，对吧？它不是最重要的事情。
thing for who you are. And you know, it's okay if you don't know what you want to do. It's okay if you're feeling a little bit lost. This is a significant transition, perhaps one of the biggest ones that will make before retirement. So be kind to yourself. And what I really want to to talk about next is some tips I have for addressing that feeling of being a little bit aimless, feeling a little bit unhappy, confused post-graduation, and also how to manage some of that career confusion. It's all fine and good for me to sit here and reassure you that you'll be fine, but I also think that a lot of us benefit from some practical steps towards where we're going, some practical steps forward. So we are going to talk about all of that and more after this short break.
事情关乎你是谁。你知道的，如果你不知道自己想做什么，也没关系。如果你觉得有点迷失，也没关系。这是一次重大的转变，也许是我们在退休前要经历的最大转变之一。所以要对自己好一点。而我接下来真正想谈的是，我对于解决那种有点漫无目的、有点不快乐、毕业后感到困惑的感觉的一些建议，以及如何应对其中一些职业困惑。我坐在这里向你保证你会没事的，这当然很好也很容易，但我也认为我们很多人都会从朝着我们前进的方向迈出一些实际步骤、迈出一些实际步伐中受益。所以我们将在短暂的休息后讨论所有这些以及更多内容。
2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more. to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress.
2%。这就是在有自动扶梯可用时，依然选择走楼梯的人数比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特，欢迎收听我的播客《2%》。我将在节目中剖析在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中，精神坚韧、保持体能以及培养韧性的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等展开对话。超越主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的相信种子油本质上会引起炎症。我们搞错了。我们在世界上惊慌失措的许多问题，都是压力的结果。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-Persent on the I-Hart Radio app. Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tap Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at It podcast.
经历一些磨难，你会破茧成蝶，成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的自己。在i-Hart Radio应用上收听《2%》。即T-W-O-Persent。苹果播客，或在你获取播客的任何地方。你还记得黛安娜·罗斯在VMA颁奖典礼上双击莉儿·金的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时？我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟莉儿·金到底有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《回首当年》播客中找到答案。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 was big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so you all know.
我是山姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利什。每集节目中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。包括最近一期与马克·拉蒙特·希尔的节目，畅谈80年代的快克。需要说明的是，84年对我很重要，不仅仅是因为快克。我随时准备聊聊快克，但只是为了让大家知道。
I mean, at this point, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you finishing that sentence. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history.
我的意思是，此时此刻，这是我们讨论快克的第二集了。所以我开始看出这里有一条贯穿线。我们现在也把艾滋病摆上台面了。谢谢你把那句话说完。我认为对黑人群体而言，没有比这更重要的年份了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人群体而言最重要的年份之一。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Keer Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we, are in possession of the thing, and we're still chasing it, and we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses.
在iHeartRadio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《回首当年》。欢迎收听我的新播客《知难而进》，我是你的主播、你最喜欢的治疗师科尔·盖恩斯。为了致敬心理健康意识月，我带来了我自己在心理健康领域十多年的经验，以及与众多不可思议的嘉宾的对话。我说的是特里普·方丹、瑞安·克拉克。有时，当我们追逐某样东西时，我们太过于沉迷于追逐本身，以至于没有意识到我们其实已经拥有了这样东西，而我们还在追逐它，并且不知道什么时候才算足够。因为人们盯着记分牌。生活变成了关于输赢。
Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth, or are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, is we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast,
史蒂夫·“伯恩斯”、达斯汀·罗斯，因为你觉得在世期间做一个好人很重要，还是你做一个好人是因为你害怕？因为那是两种不同的动机，兄弟。绝对是。那是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你真正地做一个好人。和我（科尔·盖恩斯）一起，在我的新播客中进行关于治愈、成长、父亲身份、压力和目标的真实对话。
Learn the Hardway. Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story.
《知难而进》。打开你免费的iHeartRadio应用。搜索《知难而进》并立即收听。2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己处于一场父权鉴定丑闻的中心。随后的家庭法庭听证会揭露了他故事中明显的矛盾之处。
This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in someone, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detection. detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected.
这开启了长达数年的法庭之战来证明真相。你伪造了这份特定的检测报告两次，对吧？我伪造了一次检测。这需要一大批互联网侦探来破案。我希望人们能够看到他们的税款被用在了哪里。阳光是最好的消毒剂。
They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Lesbian and Michael Naranjini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences.
他们将揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格·莱斯利和迈克尔·纳兰吉尼。我的天哪。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《情网难逃》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于要承担后果了。
Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Maricopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Feeling lost does not come with an easy exit plan. I think if that was the case, we wouldn't be feeling that way in the first place, right? Like, that's the irony. If we could just snap our fingers and suddenly find our calling, we would all be doing.
女士们先生们，马里科帕县传来突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被指控犯有欺诈罪。在亚利桑那州，在正义得到伸张之前，这件事还没完。在iheart radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《情网难逃》播客。感到迷茫并没有一个简单的退路计划。我想如果真是那样的话，我们一开始就不会有这种感觉了，对吧？这就是讽刺之处。如果我们能打个响指突然找到我们的天职，我们大家都会去做的。
we would all be doing that. On that point, I don't actually think there is such a thing as a calling or one thing on this planet that we were each made to do, only one thing. Instead, I think we all have certain aptitudes, things that we excel at, and discovering what those are is what allows us to discover a whole number of things that we would be good at, perhaps equally, that we would love doing equally. That aptitude combined with our passion, what kind of lights our soul, what provides us with a sense of drive and mission and meaning,
我们大家都会那样做了。说到这一点，我其实并不认为有什么所谓的天职，或者在这个星球上我们每个人生来就注定要做的一件事，只有唯一的一件事。相反，我认为我们都有某些天赋，也就是我们擅长的事情，而发现这些是什么，能让我们发现一系列我们同样擅长、可能同样热爱的事情。这种天赋结合我们的激情——那种点燃我们灵魂的东西、给我们提供驱动力、使命感和意义感的东西——
is kind of the formula to minimizing that sense of career confusion and having a sense forward, having a sense of a path forward, I guess. So what you need to find is that combination of aptitude and passion. And that won't always be, obvious, but here's how you can identify it. Identifying aptitude is the easiest step, so let's start there. Here's kind of a few questions I often refer to, and I want you to mentally answer them, and I want you to answer them honestly. What kind of tasks are you most excited to do in your daily
某种程度上这就是将这种职业困惑降到最低的公式，并且拥有一种向前迈进的感觉，拥有一种前行道路的感觉，我猜是这样的。所以你需要找到的是天赋与激情的结合。这并不总是显而易见的，但以下是你如何识别它的方法。识别天赋是最简单的一步，所以我们从那开始。这里有一些我经常参考的问题，我希望你在脑海中回答它们，我希望你诚实地回答它们。在你的日常生活中，你最兴奋去完成的任务是什么？
life, but also in your professional life? When do you feel like you are in a flow state? So a flow state is a mental state where we are entirely focused on a single activity and time passes quite quickly without us knowing. Do you like to plan or are you okay to be led and let others plan? What kind of skills come naturally to you? Is it talking to people and feeling like they always open up? Maybe being able to really easily rationalize ideas to form really good arguments. maybe you're creative, do you have a really aesthetic brain? I have one friend Sarah, shout out to Sarah, I fucking love her, but Sarah has this really aesthetic eye. And I do not. She can really easily
生活，还有你的职业生活？什么时候你觉得自己进入了心流状态？所以心流状态是一种心理状态，在这个状态下我们完全专注于单一的活动，时间在不知不觉中飞逝。你喜欢做计划，还是愿意顺其自然、让别人来做计划？什么样技能是你生来就擅长的？是和人交谈，让他们觉得总是对你敞开心扉？也许是能够非常轻松地将想法合理化，从而形成非常有说服力的论点。也许你很有创造力，你有一个真正充满美感的大脑？我有一个朋友萨拉，向萨拉致敬，我他妈太爱她了，但萨拉有一种真正审美的眼光。而我没有。她可以非常轻松地
make things incredibly beautiful and she sees potential for beauty in very everyday things and really brings that beauty out. You know, I look at her and I look at me and I'm like, okay, that's something that we're different at. She has this very unique aptitude and skill for doing those things. There are just some abilities which psychologists theorize just come more naturally to some people rather than others. And maybe that's based on our temperament, our perspective, how our brains process information. But instead of trying to do the things that you are not good at and beating yourself up because you are not like someone else in some department, focus on the things that you bring to the table.
把事情变得不可思议的美丽，并且她在非常日常的事物中看到美的潜力，并真正把这种美展现出来。你知道，我看着她，再看看我自己，我就想，好吧，这是我们俩不同的地方。她有着这种非常独特的才能和技能来做这些事情。有些能力，心理学家理论上认为，对某些人来说就是比对其他人更自然地拥有。也许这是基于我们的气质、我们的视角、我们的大脑处理信息的方式。但与其去尝试你并不擅长的东西，并因为自己在某些部门不像别人而责备自己，不如专注于你所带来的东西。
if they are not as deeply acknowledged or even if people aren't as ready to praise them, those skills are always needed. Every single skill that someone has has a place. So discovering your passion is another thing. But I have some questions for that as well. And I think also the thing with passion is that sometimes it can be subconscious. So that's why when I say these questions, I want you to think about them really deeply and without bias. And so, authentically without thinking about what you think someone else would want you to say. What would you do in your spare time if you had no time constraints? What did you love doing as a child? What did you always aspire to be as a child? And do you still harbor that dream?
即使它们没有得到深度的认可，甚至即使人们不像过去那样随时准备称赞它们，这些技能总是被需要的。每个人拥有的每一项技能都有其用武之地。所以，发现你的热情是另一回事。但我对此也有一些问题。而且我也认为，关于热情的一点是，有时它可能是潜意识的。所以这就是为什么当我提出这些问题时，我希望你真正深入地去思考它们，不要带有偏见。真实地思考，而不用去想你认为别人会希望你说什么。如果你没有时间限制，你在业余时间会做什么？你小时候最喜欢做什么？你小时候一直渴望成为什么样的人？你现在还怀揣着那个梦想吗？
What are the compliments that people give you that you often overlook? What do people come to you for is it advice or is it for something really practical, something intuitive, even fixing clothes or for travel advice or asking you to take pictures of them? What is intuitive for you that others can also see? And finally, I know it is such a cliche question, but what would you do if money was no option? You know, what would you do if money was no option? Obviously, money is a factor in a lot the decisions that we make, but pretend it isn't for a second. And answer without prejudice here, without thinking about what's impractical or what your family wants or what society expects, what is the thing that you could spend hours doing that would make you feel most fulfilled.
人们给你的、而你经常忽视的赞美是什么？人们来找你寻求什么，是寻求建议还是寻求一些非常实际的东西，一些直观的东西，甚至是修理衣服、寻求旅游建议，或者是请你帮他们拍照？什么对你来说是直观的，而别人也能看出来的？最后，我知道这是一个非常陈词滥调的问题，但如果金钱不是问题，你会做什么？你知道，如果金钱不是问题，你会做什么？显然，金钱是我们做出的许多决定中的一个因素，但请假装它暂时不是。带着不带偏见的态度回答，不要去想什么是不切实际的，或者你的家庭想要什么，或者社会期望什么，那件你可以花上几个小时去做、并能让你感到最充实的事情是什么。
I think the one thing that stops us from doing what we love more than anything else is the fear of it not working out or the fear of failure. And that comes from a lot of secondary fears, a fear of embarrassment, a fear of disappointing people, a fear of rejection or injuring our self-esteem. But here's the mentality I always adopt. If you don't do the thing that you are afraid of, if you don't take the risk, or at least give it a try, the only person that you are letting down is yourself. That is the case. The only person you are letting down is yourself. the only person who will have to deal with that what if that regret is you. And there is nothing that can't be undone except for the choices that you didn't make.
我认为阻止我们做自己热爱的事情的头号阻力，莫过于害怕事情无法成功或害怕失败。这来自于许多次要的恐惧，对尴尬的恐惧，对让人失望的恐惧，对拒绝的恐惧，或者对损害我们自尊的恐惧。但这就是我一直采用的心态。如果你不做你害怕的事情，如果你不承担风险，或者至少去尝试一下，你唯一辜负的人就是你自己。事实确实如此。你唯一辜负的人就是你自己，那个不得不面对“如果当时……”这种遗憾的人只有你自己。没有什么不能被撤销，除了你没有做出的选择。
Even if it's a small risk, something that you do on the weekends or in your spare time, the pursuit of your dreams, however small, is never a waste. And I don't think it will ever be something that you wish you didn't do. The same goes for so many other opportunities and jobs. the mistake we make there that really hurts our sense of self and general happiness during this decade is feeling like we are locked into the first career or decision we make straight out of university. Maybe you need the reminder that you can always change. What is right for you right now may not be right for you in a few years, but do not forget your agency that your decisions
即使这是一个很小的风险，你在周末或业余时间做的事情，追求你的梦想，无论多么渺小，也绝不是浪费。而且我认为这绝不会是你希望自己当初没有做过的事情。许多其他机会和工作也是如此。我们在那个阶段犯的错误，真正伤害了我们对自我的认知和在这十年的整体幸福感，就是觉得自己被锁定了刚走出大学校门时做出的第一份职业或决定的束缚中。也许你需要提醒自己，你总是可以改变的。现在对你来说正确的事情，几年后可能就不对了，但不要忘记你的自主权，你的决定
make changes, that your decisions allow you to choose different. differently. You are not going to be the same person every year of your life. You know, what's the statistic? The average person tends to go through three to seven careers or jobs before they retire. So don't be afraid to participate in a bit of trial and error when it comes to the work you want to do, especially at a time in your life where I think youth affords you a lot of privileges, the ability to make mistakes and recover, the ability to change without so many people hold. holding you responsible for their own well-being, the ability to turn around and choose entirely differently. You don't need to justify those choices to anyone. It's your life. You are allowed
会带来改变，你的决定允许你做出不同的选择。不同地选择。你不会成为你生命中每年的同一个人。你知道，统计数据是什么？普通人在退休前往往要经历三到七个职业或工作。所以，当涉及到你想做的工作时，不要害怕参与一点试错，尤其是在你人生的这个阶段，我认为年轻赋予了你很多特权，犯错和恢复的能力，在没有那么多人要求你对他们的幸福负责的情况下改变的能力，转身做出完全不同选择的能力。你不需要向任何人证明这些选择是合理的。这是你的人生。你被允许
to make mistakes and choose differently. I think that's important to remember. Additionally, if you're feeling a little bit lost after graduating, as I very much did, here's some further pieces of advice. Instead of thinking and trying to envision what success looks like for you professionally or what your five-year plan should be because I think we all know those plans never work out how we think they will. I want you to imagine one day in your life five years from now in as much detail as possible. And we've done this exercise on the podcast before, but I think it is important to do this regularly. What would a day in your life where you are immensely happy look like in five years. You know, where are you living? Where do you wake up in the morning? What does your
犯错并做出不同的选择。我认为记住这一点很重要。此外，如果你在毕业后感到有点迷茫，就像我曾经非常迷茫的那样，这里有一些进一步的建议。与其去思考和试图构想你的职业成功是什么样子，或者你的五年计划应该是什么，因为我想我们都知道那些计划从来不会像我们想象的那样奏效。我希望你尽可能详细地想象五年后你生活中的一天。我们以前在播客上做过这个练习，但我认为定期这样做是很重要的。五年后，你无比快乐的一天会是什么样子。你知道，你住在哪里？你早上在哪里醒来？你的
room look like? What are you having for breakfast? Where are you off to afterwards? Who are you talking to throughout the day? What kind of things are on your schedule? What do you do after work? Who are you having dinner with? What are you celebrating? What are you looking forward to? Those small details when we picture them, they are the source of what will actually make us happy. what you picture is what you truly value and what you value in the ordinary and the everyday life of your future self. And the other beauty of this exercise is that there are a million different paths and choices, little divvets in the journey that can get you to that dream day, that can get you to that dream life in five years. Some of them are intentional and some of them are accidental.
房间是什么样的？你早餐吃什么？之后你要去哪里？你一整天都在和谁说话？你的日程表上有什么样的事情？你下班后做什么？你在和谁吃晚餐？你在庆祝什么？你在期待什么？当我们想象这些小细节时，它们就是真正能让我们快乐的源泉。你所想象的就是你真正珍视的东西，以及你在未来的普通和日常生活所珍视的东西。这个练习的另一个美妙之处在于，有成百上千条不同的道路和选择，旅程中的小波折可以让你到达那个梦想的一天，在五年内带你走向那种梦想的生活。其中一些是有意的，一些是偶然的。
That is important to remember. You cannot control for everything that is going to happen in your life. Both the good and the bad. So when we exit university and we feel like we need to like immediately make this five-year plan and stick to everything, it doesn't always leave us room to be flexible and room to kind of accept the surprises that life throws us. Secondly, try not to get lost in the nostalgia of the good old days. Nostalgia is a beautiful emotion and important one that brings a sense of life purpose, of good times, of optimism, but when we spend too much time wanting to return to the past, we don't focus on how we can make our current life and future life
记住这一点很重要。你无法控制你生命中将要发生的一切。无论是好的还是坏的。因此，当我们离开大学，觉得我们需要立即制定这个五年计划并坚持一切时，它并不总是给我们留出灵活性和接受生活抛给我们的惊喜的空间。其次，尽量不要迷失在过去美好旧日的怀旧情绪中。怀旧是一种美丽的情感，也是一种重要的情感，它带来了一种生活目标感、美好时光感和乐观主义，但当我们花太多时间想要回到过去时，我们就没有专注于我们如何让当前的生活和未来生活
even greater and even better. Longing for the past for your carefree college days, for your friends, for all the memories, for all the parties, and feeling like you'll never get those back, you'll never experience that again, can fuel dissatisfaction, and can also manifest in a lot of stagnation, but also nostalgic depression, a yearning for some time or something gone. And psychologists did actually consider this a mental health
变得更加宏大和美好。渴望过去无忧无虑的大学时代、你的朋友、所有的记忆、所有的派对，并觉得你永远不会把那些找回来，你永远不会再经历那种经历，这会助长不满，也可能表现在大量的停滞不前中，还有怀旧性的抑郁，对某种消逝的时间或事物的渴望。心理学家实际上将此视为一种心理健康
condition for a long time. You know, from like the 1600s to the 1800s, nostalgia was literally a mental health condition. And we all know that person from high school or university, who has not been able to move on from the memories that they made during that period of time. It's almost like Peter Pan syndrome, wanting to be forever stuck in those very young carefree moments, not wanting to grow up. Remember, you can't always trust your memories. Sometimes when we look back at the past, we are doing so through a filter of what we call rosy retrospection.
长久以来的状况。你知道，从1600年代到1800年代，怀旧简直就是一种心理健康状况。我们都知道高中或大学里的那种人，他们一直无法从那段时期创造的回忆中走出来。这有点像彼得潘综合症，想要永远困在那些非常年轻、无忧无虑的时刻里，不想长大。记住，你并不总是能相信你的记忆。有时当我们回顾过去时，我们是通过所谓的“玫瑰色回忆”滤镜来进行的。
And it's this tendency to ignore unpleasant details in the past, only focus on the good, causing us to feel like what we're currently experiencing doesn't have the same feeling. In those moments where you think the best years of your life are behind you, remind yourself that in five years time, you're going to be thinking the same way about where you are now. It's like when we look back at old photos of ourselves where we know at the time we probably thought we looked terrible or ugly or some kind of way. But when we look at them now, we're like, wow, we were so beautiful. I looked great. I totally did not take advantage of how hot I was. The same will go for this new chapter, even the new challenges, even the nostalgia.
这是倾向于忽略过去令人不快细节的趋势，只关注美好的一面，导致我们觉得我们目前正在经历的事情没有那种感觉。在那些你认为人生中最美好的岁月已经过去的时刻，提醒自己，五年后，你也会以同样的方式看待你现在所处的地方。就像我们回看自己的老照片时，我们知道当时我们可能觉得自己看起来很糟糕、很丑或者有什么问题。但当我们现在看着它们时，我们会想，哇，我们太美了。我看起来棒极了。我完全没有好好利用我当时有多辣。这个新篇章也是如此，甚至是新的挑战，甚至是怀旧。
You'll one day see that as part of the journey that is bringing you to your future self. Also, this is a bit of a tangent and kind of unrelated, but just get off LinkedIn. Please, if you are on LinkedIn, if you're someone who has a tendency to engage in upward social comparison where you are always judging yourself against the accomplishments of others, that platform is only going to intensify your feeling of insecurity. You don't need to see what anyone else is doing to know that you're doing what's right for you. You don't need to see that old classmate or co-worker or your high school valedictorian.
有一天你会把这看作是把你带向未来自我的旅程的一部分。此外，这有点题外话，也有些无关，但请离开LinkedIn。求你了，如果你在使用LinkedIn，如果你是一个倾向于进行向上社会比较的人，总是拿自己和别人的成就作比较，那个平台只会加剧你的不安全感。你不需要看别人在做什么就知道你在做对你来说正确的事。你不需要看到那个老同学、同事或你的高中毕业生代表。
Your life and your goals and your path has incredible meaning without needing the validation of comparing it to another person's journey. you know, people's progress is always going to be different. And remember, with any big life transition, you know, you just graduated university. You have graduated university. That is a significant accomplishment, but there will be stress. There will be moments of utter confusion and panic and feeling that like adrenaline rush to figure it all out right now. You know, it's 3 a.m. in the morning and suddenly you get the urge to look at whether you qualify for a master's degree or you start applying for new jobs. Slow down. You have time. Every person you idolize, every person you admire
你的人生、目标和道路有着不可思议的意义，不需要通过与另一个人的旅程进行比较来获得认可。你知道，人们的进步总是不同的。请记住，伴随着任何重大的人生转变，你知道，你刚刚毕业。你已经大学毕业了。这是一个重大的成就，但会有压力。会有完全困惑和恐慌的时刻，以及那种想马上搞清楚一切的肾上腺素飙升的感觉。你知道，凌晨3点，突然你有一种强烈的冲动，想看看自己是否有资格攻读硕士学位，或者你开始申请新工作。慢下来。你有时间。你崇拜的每一个人，你钦佩的每一个人
or look up to has experienced the same thing has had those feelings. It has taken them years and they have found themselves and they're continuing to discover themselves as you are. And as a final reminder for my post-uny people out there feeling super aimless, every emotional state, every feeling that you have is temporary. This feeling is temporary. You will push through and build new community and find new people and new meaning. And you will, I think, kind of be grateful for the struggle and what it gave you, what you've learned. You know, I really do believe that having survived my panic years, the things I'm most grateful for are the things that I didn't get because they brought me to a better place.
或者敬仰的人都经历过同样的事情，都有过这些感受。这花了他们很多年，他们找到了自己，并且像你一样，他们正在继续探索自己。作为给我那些超级没有方向感的大学毕业生的最后提醒，每一种情感状态，你所拥有的每一种感觉都是暂时的。这种感觉是暂时的。你会挺过去，建立新的社区，找到新的人和新的意义。而且我认为，你会对这种挣扎以及它给你的东西、你所学到的东西心存感激。你知道，我真的相信，在经历了我的恐慌岁月之后，我最感激的事情是我没有得到的东西，因为它们把我带到了一个更好的地方。
Not because that sounds so like spiritual. They brought me to a better place. But no, honestly, like, there are some parts of your journey that you really just can't account for. And you kind of just have to trust, like, the wave of the tides and the moves of the winds and everything that's happening around you that you can't anticipate all the little surprises and opportunities that you cannot anticipate. And that's kind of the beauty of this chapter.
不是因为这听起来多么有灵性。它们把我带到了一个更好地方。但说实话，不，有些部分的旅程你真的无法解释。你只能去信任，比如潮水的波涛、风的移动以及周围发生的一切，你无法预料你无法预料的所有小惊喜和机会。而这正是这个篇章的美妙之处。
The beauty of this period is that you can do anything. You can do anything that you want with your time. You are young. you are carefree. There are so many seasons of life you let to live, so do not lose sight of that. I sincerely hope that you have enjoyed this episode. If there is someone in your life who needs to hear this, a friend, a co-worker, a sister, anyone at all, please feel free to share it with them. You have no idea if it will help them out. So thank you, as always, for tagging along for listening today. If you enjoyed this episode, please, feel free to give it a five-star review on Apple Podcasts,
这个时期的美妙之处在于你可以做任何事。你可以用你的时间做任何你想做的事。你还年轻。你无忧无虑。你还有很多生命的季节要去经历，所以不要忽视这一点。我真心希望你喜欢这一集。如果你的生活中有人需要听到这个，一个朋友、一个同事、一个姐姐，任何人，请随时与他们分享。你不知道这是否能帮助他们。所以像往常一样，感谢你今天一路陪伴收听。如果你喜欢这一集，请随时在苹果播客上给它一个五星评价，
Spotify, wherever you are listening right now. Follow us at that psychology podcast. If you have an episode suggestion, if you have something that you want to contribute to this conversation, I love reading when people have different opinions to me or when there's something that maybe I miss that we can include in another episode. So I appreciate you listening along today. I appreciate your attention. Thank you so much. And as always, we will be back next week with another episode. Two percent. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some
Spotify，无论你现在在哪里收听。在that psychology podcast上关注我们。如果你有剧集建议，如果你有什么想为这次对话做贡献的，我喜欢看人们有不同意见的时候，或者当我错过了什么我们可以纳入另一集的内容时。所以我很感激你今天的收听。感谢你的关注。非常感谢。像往常一样，我们下周将带着另一集回归。百分之二。这是当自动扶梯也可用的情况下走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了坚韧精神、健康体魄的科学，以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立韧性的方法。让自己经历一些
hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilling. old healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast.
艰难困苦，你就会以一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人的身份从另一端走出来。收听《2%》。即IHeartRadio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方上的TWO%。在《回看过去》播客中。
For 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84's big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it with our friends,
对于1979年来说，那对我来说是一个重要的时刻。84年对我来说意义重大。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利ッシュ。每一集，我们挑选一年，剖析发生了什么，并试图弄清楚我们是如何和我们的朋友们、
fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild. It was a wild. A wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all?
同行的喜剧演员以及最喜欢的作家一起挺过这一切的。就像马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈论80年代一样。84年是一个疯狂的年份。这是一个疯狂的年份。疯狂的一年。我认为对于黑人来说没有比这更重要的一年了。在IHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《回看过去》。嘿，最近怎么样，伙计们？
You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host, Kier Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor? It signals to the world that you're not to be. be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy
你正在收听由你最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人基尔·盖姆斯主持的《艰难学习》。这个空间是关于黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都真的不安全进行的坦诚对话，但你是在和一个知道自己在做什么的持牌专业人士进行这些对话。多少人穿着一套盔甲？它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这个能力并不意味着你需要这样做。在AHA广播应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《艰难学习》。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的父亲。但这次怀孕
appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police.
似乎是一个骗局。欧文斯女士，你两次篡改了这个特定的测试，对吗？我篡改了一次测试。这动用了一大批互联网侦探才揭露出一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格·吉莱斯皮和迈克尔·马拉蒂尼。我的脑洞大开。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《受困的爱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。
As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面对了后果。在IHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《受困的爱》播客。这是一个IHeart播客。保证是人类。这一集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子来发表评论。